just a warning before you continue this
video that it is going to discuss Eating
Disorders so in a recent interview the
actor who played Juanita on Desperate
Housewives revealed that she developed
an eating disorder at seven years old
due to people's response to her
character her name is Madison De La
Garza and you might also know that she's
Demi Lovato's half-sister so Juanita is
Gabby's oldest daughter and the whole
joke of Juanita's character as Madison
pointed out is that she's the complete
opposite of her mother who is like this
Thin Beautiful supermodel and Madison
said that she was shocked by people's
reactions to her character she shared
that people try to discuss their
judgment of her as concerns for her
health and she said that at like seven
and eight years old she was already
spending hours and hours on the computer
just reading mean comments online about
her appearance and she explained that
this led to her starving herself and
developing an eating disorder at that
age she also added that Eva Longoria who
played her mother went out of her way to
make her feel special and pretty and
like family and so that she would be
comfortable if she ever wanted to talk
about these things